I met him once and he was very proud
should be and to have so many films that
stand the test of time after all of the
immense improvements and technological
advances that have happened is quite
amazing I mean my favorite movie is the
time machine which i think is a an
example of a movie that Moxxi do
entirely on heart it's it's one of the
most moving drama science fiction
pictures that I've ever seen partly
because of the actors Rod Taylor and
Alan Young who are brilliant in it
the music score is great and it's not
these pictures you got to remember we're
medium budget movies I mean nobody ever
gave George a lot of money it's a
director to do a picture - director
produce a picture he had to use his
ingenuity and the time machine is a
movie that actually won an Oscar for
Best Visual Effects and when seem today
some of the visual effects are marvelous
at the 25th anniversary George and I sat
in the back row drinking champagne and
having a marvelous time and I said oh
please I finally have you I've got to
ask you what were the three books
wouldn't know no he said that's up to
you you need quite frankly I don't know
I couldn't believe that I finally got to
meet George pal he was something else
what a lovely man and at the 25th
anniversary when people were standing
out for hours outside the Holly theater
- just to see the the War of the Worlds
and when worlds collide and they had to
run it like three or four times to get
everybody in it ran all night long
George had a lot of unrealized projects
he there were a number of pictures that
he wanted to do that he was unable to do
and partly because sometimes as with all
movies that we make some of them make
money and some of them don't
some of them work and some of them don't
he did when worlds collide and it was
very popular and it was a terrific
picture it's been remade a number of
times unofficially but he he wanted to
make a sequel called after worlds
collide but when conquest of space came
out and nobody seemed to find it
interesting enough to attend they
decided the Paramount decided not to
make that he also was supposed to do
Logan's Run
before the Logans around that we're
familiar with and that was unfortunately
he made a picture called the power for
the same studio and the power was is a
very interesting movie that doesn't work
and that didn't make any money and so
Logan's Run ended up being made by other
people he was there was also when the
sleeper wakes which was an HG Wells
story that he wanted to do and that
didn't work out because Woody Allen made
sleeper and it was almost the same story
so he they said no and then he was gonna
do the time traveler which was a sequel
to the time machine and that just
happened to be around the time that time
after time came out my memories of
George where else great sensitivity
warmth humor know he had a brain he was
always thinking always thinking but
kindly he saw the world through
beautiful eyes and he was able to
transfer that onto the screen and I
think we were very lucky I remember one
one story was we were on the backlot
shooting the bel air fire happened and
of course George was directing the seven
phases of dr. Lao and they came to him
and said his wife was on the phone and
he was - I was standing there I happened
to be standing there when he got the
phone call and he said I don't know what
I can do you know it was a horrible fire
they they told her she had to leave she
couldn't take anything I think they lost
all their their baby pictures and he
just stayed there he said what else can
I do we just shot the movie his Oscar
burns that he was given as a honorary
Oscar the honorary Oscar I shot that
Oscar the original Oscar and the title
credits which should have been on on the
in Kapoor film but they used the old
credits there but I shot a title credit
there with the Oscar and the glass
plates and I came down to a to a kiosk
with 30 puppets going around in the
circle all in a different cycle took a
month to do it I was sorry I didn't see
it tonight
but that Oscar so much for restoration
he used to keep that Oscar it was all
molten in a little ball like that he
kept that that Oscar forever and ever
the original Oscar they gave him another
one of course from the Academy
you